thank you
okay I'm here with the first lady of
Florida Casey DeSantis and Casey well
first off where are you right now and
really I just want to spend a couple
minutes telling the people how they can
help because that's what this is all
about right now
yeah I'll tell you what Dave well first
of all thank you I'm at the Emergency
Operations Center in Tallahassee we have
hundreds upon hundreds of people
responding here and then of course you
know we have tens of thousands of people
responding to the affected area you
using your megaphone and your voice to
try to get people to help is just so
imperative and we thank you one of the
things I know you did personally was
help us get a hundred thousand dollars
which contributed to the 13 million that
we have been able to raise through the
disaster fund Florida
disasterfund.org that money is
particularly helpful it's coming from
private sector dollars and why it's so
nice is because we are working with the
Emergency Operations at Center we're
getting all of the needs that are coming
in here and they're working with the
private sector entities to get money
quickly out to the ground in the
affected areas and supporting those
non-profits that are on the front lines
so there's a lot of things that people
can do but primarily the funds is a
great way to start
so we're going to put the link of course
down below so that people can donate and
I know that people in my audience have
already and will continue to do so uh
what about Beyond donations in terms of
actually physically helping I'm getting
a lot of messages from people that they
have some skills they they want to help
they want to get down to Southwest
Florida are you guys coordinating any of
that or what can people do yes yes we
are so one thing people have said is I
want to go down there I want to get on
the ground I want to go instantaneously
just know that there is still a mission
going on to rescue folks and we have the
National Guard we have the Coast Guard
we have our First Responders law
enforcement who are going around in
those affected areas and Fort Myers
Beach and Sanibel Island and some of the
barrier islands and they're going into
making sure that people are okay but
what you can do is go to
volunteerflorida.org once you get there
there's something called volunteer
connect that is a portal that we are
using as a path through pass-through to
the non-profits that are again on the
ground on the front lines and they are
are looking for support so the American
Red Cross is looking for boots on the
ground because right now we have 600
trucks some are already there some are
on their way from places like Louisiana
we have a lot of resources that we have
been staging here in the State of
Florida we're getting them to those
distribution points in Florida and then
we're going to need folks in addition to
the folks that are already there to
distribute things like water bottles and
food and blankets and tarps that we have
and so that is a really great way
volunteerflorida.org to figure out how
you can help firsthand if you want to be
on the ground and frankly there's some
other ways that you can donate your time
not necessarily being there in Southwest
Florida are you guys kind of Blown Away
about by the devastation of this thing I
mean it sounds like we were super
prepared that the administration did
everything possible but the size of this
thing not only you know basically one
tick below the category five but the
actual size of the hurricane and now
it's moving up South Carolina as we talk
um right it's almost like there was
almost nothing we could do in a way
well no I mean the State of Florida was
prepared for all contingencies I mean
unfortunately this is something that we
just know how to do is to prepare for
these storms they run through a lot of
scenarios here we have a greater
management director here at the EOC who
has gone through a lot of contingency
plans so we had assets staged and ready
to go in the form of food and water
bottles and MREs we had 40 000 linesmen
from Florida Power and Light and other
places that were ready to go to make
sure that they were on the ground to
restore things like power we have the
Army Corps of Engineers that responded
to a water problem down in Lee County
they were there within a matter of hours
at two o'clock in the morning they
showed up to try to make a difference so
we had things staged but to your point
about this storm I mean I think we all
saw the cone there was the kind of the
cone uncertainty at one point in time it
was coming up towards the Panhandle and
then it shifted and went South I think
what was really shocking about this
storm was the size the storm surge and
how slowly it came on Shore and then
slowly least snaked its way up to
northeast Florida and as we see now
exiting into the Atlantic and going up
towards South Carolina and so it dumped
a lot of rain there's been some flooding
incidents all across the State Seminole
County Volusia County we're hearing
about flooding and so it was just a
monster storm that moved very quickly
and when you were down there when I was
down there with the governor
we went and toured the the area Fort
Walton Beach we wanted up in a
helicopter you could really see where
the eye wall came on Shore and some of
the most affected areas were the
Northeast quadrant of the storm because
that's where you saw that huge storm
surge and so that's why you see a lot of
issues and a lot of Devastation which is
heartbreaking in places like Lee County
and Collier County and the northern part
of Charlotte County
yeah well I just want to say you know
I'm like the proudest new Floridian and
I want to do everything possible to to
help my state and and I'm so
appreciative of obviously uh your
husband and you and everyone here that's
doing everything possible
um Can when people are donating do they
have any direction as to where that
money goes if they care about you know
one particular area maybe that they
lived in or is this just a mass fund and
then you guys figure out what to do with
it
yeah it is a fund it's a 501c3 that's a
good question what we do is we vet a lot
of these organizations and have
Partnerships and mou's going into it
memorandums of understanding about what
they do and what services they will
provide given the needs that we are
finding on the ground and so one of the
great things that you could know about
this fund is that it's going to go to
the directly to the people who need it
most another great thing is I went in
and we we waived all of the processing
fees there's not going to be a three
percent cut from here we talked to visa
and American Express and PayPal was
really great and they waived all those
fees so you know when you're donating to
that 501c3 that it is going to go
directly to the folks who are on the
ground executing the mission
great well listen I know you're
incredibly busy and I'm guessing you
probably have to get back out on the
road soon enough and uh we're just all
with you guys if there's anything else I
can do as I said we're going to put the
link down below and do you have any
other any other thoughts Before I Let
You Go no I'll tell you what Dave I mean
we welcome you with open arms as a new
Floridian I know there's a lot of new
Floridians have come here for freedom
and we just want people to know that we
have your back those who are suffering I
mean we're going to be with you until
this is done and you're on your feet and
you're back and and going back at things
as they once were were very resilient in
Florida I couldn't be more proud as you
have said to be a Floridian watching the
response and being down in Southwest
Florida seeing people come together
helping one another in need not leaving
people until they know that the job is
done I mean I am very proud to be a
Floridian I'm very proud of the
governor's response to this and very
proud of the hundreds of people here at
the EOC and all of the First Responders
the tens of thousands of people not only
from Florida but all across the country
that are coming to support the efforts
and so
um you know it's it's it's awful it's
tragic what's happened to so many people
but I couldn't be more proud of the way
that the state is responding
same here well thank you so much and
best obviously to the governor and to
the family and everyone that's with you
up there and uh you know keep me posted
on how I can help yeah yeah thanks Dave
and best to your family I know they had
a home on Sanibel so we were we're
thinking of them
[Music]